[Music]
you know I love chasing epiphanies you
know I tell people that to make art is a
desire to clothe inspiration right to
capture the transient fleeting moments
in which the dots connect in a new way
it's this idea that when we are at our
most creative we aren't even really
creating we're channeling we are
transcribing we are we are conduits for
something larger than ourselves to erupt
to express itself through us we become a
medium we become an instruments being
played by some other sentience you know
this sounds like the musing the muses of
the madness of the Greek creative people
who talked about being touched by a hint
of madness and something erupting
through them but not from them and
though it is with them it belongs not to
them creativity as a holy act creativity
as divine grace is in at least allow us
to be allows us to be humble it allows
us to succumb to surrender to dive in to
lose ourselves or something even
beautiful about that there's something
kind of beautiful about getting out of
our own way or right which people talk
about when they talk about flow States
and creativity
oh my god when that happens that is
transcendence that is to be in ecstasy
to be beside ourselves as something
comes through and
oh that's what we're chasing that's what
we're always always chasing
[Music]